[Music]
if you want to tell a story right you
gotta start at the beginning
[Music]
we're gonna have to work together with
you don't they know I own this town
ladylike
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
that felt pretty great
[Music]
you know what a Harlequin is the
Harlequins role is to serve it's nothing
without a master no one gives two shits
who we are beyond that
the Joker and I broke up I did a fresh
start but it turns out I wasn't the only
daemon got them looking for emancipation
ocular new queen she wants me
[Applause]
who are you guys
[Music]
you're still
you need
after all of us now
we should order pizzas
[Applause]
[Music]
who's having a good time
psycho trip you'll never call a woman
check I'll accept broth lady woman
but on occasion [ __ ] anyway can I help
you
why yes yes you can I'm here to report a
terrible crime
and what terrible crime is that this one
nah [ __ ] I told this all wrong quick
history lesson this all started when the
Joker and I broke up
it was completely usual and soon enough
I was back on my feet ready to embrace
the fierce goddess within it's oh so now
that I cut ties with mr. J I'm about to
learn that a lot of people want me dead
uh alone at the top of that list is this
guy
it turns out that wasn't the only daemon
got them looking for emancipation
freedom utilities BSS what you are so
cool you're dumb enough to be building a
case against them so unless we all run
inside very unpleasant death we're gonna
have to work together
sure
psychologically speaking vengeance
rarely brings the catharsis we hope for
yeah are we ready
oh [ __ ] is that a hyena in a bottle
I named him Braves after that hunky wine
guy
[Music]